hi there today we're looking at manifold
mix-up better representations by
interpolating hidden states by because
Verma a tall number of big names on this
paper as you can see and I also saw this
at ICN also I was intrigued by it they
proposed manifold mix-up which is sort
of a regularizer of neural networks
specifically of supervised learning and
it's actually a pretty simple concept
and they kind of show that it has some
nice properties and outperforms of the
regularizer z-- so what's the problem
the problem is that if you look at this
spiral problem here which is often kind
of used to to show properties and neural
networks what you have are blue points
and the blue points on our one class and
the red points are another class you see
the two classes here are in this kind of
spiral pattern it's just the data space
is just two-dimensional so you see here
this is one class this is the other
class this is pretty difficult for a
model to learn because of course the
easy models would be like linear
classifiers but there's no way to like
put a line through this such that one
classes on one side mostly so neural
networks if you train them they will
give you something like you see here
they will try to kind of bound the
regions with the red points from the
blue points but then gets you know is it
there's some weird things like here is a
weird thing here is a weird thing so
you'd imagine a correct model would
actually classify this area as blue but
the the neural network has no concept of
of let's say that the spiral should
continue that thus it it simply sees our
here's blue here's blue here's a bit of
a gap in the training data so yeah it in
this case it assigns a red class to it
this is one problem that the decision
boundaries are rather not say squiggly
and
irregular and the second one if you look
at the actual colors full blue means
very confident blue class full red means
very confident red class and in between
you kind of see going into the the white
so if you look very closely I can
actually zoom in more here if you look
very closely you'll see that the blue
gets lighter and lighter until it
reaches white and from here the red goes
lighter and lighter until it reaches
white and white means not confident
white means like 5050 they see the that
area of not confident is actually very
small right if you consider a point here
is actually still very confident that
it's a blue point and the area of Nan
confidence is very small even though
maybe as as humans we would judge like a
relatively large band in the middle to
be not confident like if we get a point
like this and the third problem is that
you can see in multiple locations like
here or here or here that the decision
boundary is very close to the data
points unnecessarily close so especially
if you look here the decision boundary
could be much more optimally placed
probably something like this right given
the training data but the neural
networks because the only C training
data they they have no basically no
incentive to do this all right one might
think of you know something like a
support vector machine that actually has
an incentive to to put the decision
boundary away from the from the training
data but the neural networks currently
there are not SVM's they're basically
logistic regressions and as such have no
no incentive to do this so this these
are the problems the other problems are
this is the input space if you look at
the hidden space so they build neural
networks specifically they have like the
2d input and then
that goes through a bunch of layers and
then at one point there's a bottleneck
layer was just two hidden nodes and then
I guess that goes again and then it goes
into a classifier so in this bottleneck
layer they analyze the hidden
representations of the data points and
in this case for this spiral dataset
what happens is so in red you see again
the red classes in blue the blue class
it's 2d so you can plot it what it does
is it bunches up the hidden
representations fairly fairly so it
bunches them kind of up it spreads them
out in directions here here here most
are bunched up here and it does these
kind of weird arrangements here with the
pockets of those and of course the
neural network is powerful enough such
that it can actually you know separate
all of this from each other but it's not
ideal and the black dots they represent
kind of points in between or points from
the input space that are not part of the
training data so they say they sample
uniformly in the range of the input
space you see that the black dots are
all over the place right some are
confidence blue some are confident red
some are like somewhere right what you
would expect from a good model is that
if you input something that's kind of
in-between or not really sure not even
part of the input distribution that it
assigns like a low confidence to it that
it says well I'm not sure about this
this must be somewhere in the middle so
just to jump and jump forward to the
results
what does manifold mix up do without
knowing what it is in the same data set
it gives you a picture like this you see
the decision boundaries are much more
smooth right the region of no-confidence
or of low confidence indicated by the
light color is here is much larger and
also the decision boundary here we had
specifically this data point here you
see the decision boundary is pushed away
well you could argue about that
particular point but the decision
boundary
is generally pushed away from the data
points you also see no more kind of
these squiggles here it doesn't happen
in in here also if you look at the
hidden representations the hidden
representations now are spread out the
classes are bunched up so not all the
points are bunched up but the the points
of individual classes are bunched up
together and the randomly sampled points
are in the middle as they should be si
only confident red is down here
confident blue is up here and everything
in between is unconfident and third if
you look at the singular value
decomposition of the hidden layer and
that's kind of a measure of how spread
out in the different dimensions a
dataset is you see that the manifold
makes up here in green it concentrates
or it it real owers the singular values
of the kind of lower indexes so the
first singular value is large which
means that there is like a dominant
direction in the in the data and this is
done for each class separately as I
understand it it puts a lot of weight on
the first singular vector and then it
pushes down the contributions of the
other singular vector which means that
the data set that is analyzed is is
concentrated in two fewer directions of
variance this is layer one and here is
layer three means so you see it happens
in both that the manifold makes up
compared to the baseline model does this
so now you might ask what is manifold
mix-up it's actually a pretty pretty
simple concept right here is another
comparing it to other kind of
regularization techniques and showing
that none of them really does this
so manifold mix-up is this basically
what you do is when you train a neural
network you have input data and you take
mini batches of input data specifically
you take two mini batches x and y and X
prime Y Prime all right and then what
you do is if I have the draw the neural
network here so here is the inputs like
a picture of a cat
[Music]
it goes through layers right and then
what you do is you say at some
particular you say stop stop
right you take the representation up you
and you do this with two different mini
batches so here is this is cat one down
back here is cat two dog that's a
captain you pass it in right here you
take it out here you pass it through the
network and you take it out so you now
have two different forward paths of two
different mini batches and then you
define a lambda and I guess they
randomly sample a lambda in zero one
right in the range of 0 1 so this is a
mixing coefficient and then you mix you
say lambda times hidden representation
of batch 1 plus 1 minus lambda of hidden
representation of batch 2 and that is
what you pass through the rest of the
network right so basically you forward
propagate to different batches until a
certain layer here then you mix them
with a random coefficient and then you
pass it through the rest and then the
only thing you also have to do is then
at the end if you think of the labels of
these two
things you want to mix the labels in the
same fashion so you want to mix lambda
times y of batch 1 plus 1 minus lambda
of Y of batch 2 and and then this is
your training signal for whatever comes
out here right so it's it's um these are
these are one hot labels so if it's
class three its zero zero one zero zero
and if Y two is class five its zero zero
zero zero one and then you simply mix
the two alright and that becomes your
training signal so in a practical
example if let's just have a mini batch
size of one so just one sample if this
is cat and this is dog you would pass
them forward right you would mix so in
the hidden representation it would kind
of become a cat dog maybe you do it
50/50 but then you would also mix the
labels of cat and dog 5050 and tell the
net well this is a mixture of 50% cut
50% dog and then you would train the
network to predict that 50/50
coefficient so they do this the question
is at which layer do you do this and
they simply I think for each mini batch
sample one hidden layer at random they
might have someone waiting or something
but the way they describe it is they
simply sample one layer or mean per mini
batch and then do the mixing there and
then you can actually backprop through
everything everything is differentiable
this mixing is differentiable so you can
backdrop through any of everything and
there's even you know a kind of an
engineering trick to only use a single
mini batch by mixing it with itself so
that's that's pretty neat so this is
manifold mix up as you can see here is
the that's kind of the description you
mix the hidden representations with
lambda and you mix the labels with the
same lambda and that will become your
actual training signal
all right so they give some theory to it
that it flattens representations and
specifically they say under some
conditions namely if the network is
large enough so if the dimension of the
hidden representation is of a certain
size then if you optimize this manifold
mix up like if you optimize over every
London over the entire training data set
what you will end up is actually a
linear rally near function of the input
this is not too surprising that if you
because what you do is you mix linearly
this mixture happens in a linear fashion
so if you optimize for and you not only
optimize for the training set but you
optimize for every possible mixture of
the training set a linear mixture your
minimization your minimizer function
will actually become a linear function
it's not surprising but they have a
formal proof of this and they also have
a proof that if certain assumptions are
given then the minimizer's if you apply
the minimizer's the hidden
representations will actually fall on a
low dimensional subspace which is also
not surprising but it's kind of the
theoretical an analogue to what they
show with the singular value
distribution that it basically
suppresses low singular values that
means the data set is much more into a
single direction the hidden
representations sorry all right so this
the theory part is you can you can read
it if you if you want to it's yeah it's
it's - the results are to be expected I
would say from what they do and the last
thing they give a pictorial example of
why none
fold mixup flattened representations so
both of these things the fact that the
minimizer's will become linear functions
and the fact that the singular value
spectrum is more concentrated on the
first thing you'll evaluate a shion's
are flattened and here is a pictorial
representation so in this case what
happens if you if you basically have
these four data points a 1 a 2 B 1 and B
2 where a 1 and a 2 are blue class and B
1 and B 2 or red class and if you now
look at an interpolation point between
the two so if you look at this
interpolation point between a 1 and B 2
what happens is that in this case this
should be 50/50 blue and red but if you
now look at the points that it where
it's not interpolated on this is very
close to a 2 in this case it probably
should be more like 95 blue and 5 red do
they say here well if you use manifold
mix up to learn the network what you'll
actually do is you say ok actually this
hidden representation needs to be pushed
outward and you will achieve something
over here where any mixture of two
points of the opposite class will
actually give you a 50/50 so all the
midpoints here will give you a 50/50
mixture between the labels which
basically means what you end up with is
a line between this data and this data
and it means that basically the network
becomes more linear and the
representations become more flat because
flat is the optimal if you distribute
our flat all the distances to the line
are the same and this objective is
optimized and this is basically my my
kind of biggest problem with the method
is that it it kind of mixes the input
with a linear function where we know
that that is kind of not the shape of
the true data manifold the input
manifolds as you can see here the input
manifold here isn't linear or flat it's
actually very very tangled and we know
that neural networks as you continue in
the layers will flatten those
representations because ultimately at
the end it needs to classify the dataset
linearly because the last layer is a
softmax layer but the the idea that you
could apply this to any layer seems a
bit shady to me of course it works and
they show it works and it's really nice
that it works but apply applying this to
low layers and neural networks seems a
bit not principled to me so I think this
is not the end of the story of this line
of work and there is kind of more that
can be done in a more principled fashion
but in any case they show that this
actually works in terms of performance
on generalization on kind of standard
data sets so they have results on C 4 10
and C 4 100 which are famous image data
sets and they show that they have a
regularizer outperforms others and they
also show that they can withstand
one-step single step adversarial attacks
more it kind of better so they have a
better perform performance against
single step adversarial attacks
after regularizing mostly again giving
kind of an idea that the if you push if
you push it if you have a two points
this is X this is X X 1 X 2 they're of
different classes if you put the
decision boundary really close to X 2
then an adversarial attack can simply
move the point across the decision
boundary with a very small step but if
you actually have the decision boundary
pushed away from both data points then
the an adversarial attack must go a very
long way to the decision boundary and
thus if you limit the size of
adversarial attacks which is what you
usually do you can maybe not reach this
decision boundary and thus you mitigate
some of the problem so it's pretty cool
I think yeah there's work to be done but
I think this is pretty cool it's
implemented pretty easy I I've seen
there's a lot of libraries already
available with it in and yeah won't hurt
to add this to your code and make your
network better and more robust all right
that was it from me bye bye